for the last two decades some of the
biggest gaming news and reveals have
come during the electronic entertainment
expo or
e3 the yearly video game industry trade
show where the newest titles and
products are on full display many for
the first time
but even though the show has drawn tens
of thousands of people
to its convention centers every summer
the show itself has gone through
a whole lot of changes during this 27
year long run
well 26 if you exclude the cancel one
last year
so let's take a look back at the history
of e3 and maybe laugh at all the dorky
90s outfits strap yourself
in cause we're going to e3
here we are in 1985 the gaming industry
was attempting to recover from the
market crash two years prior and
ces the consumer electronics show was
the primary convention for hardware
makers to show off the newest consoles
and games
video games would continue to thrive
after the release of the nintendo
entertainment system but there still
wasn't a dedicated gaming convention
for all the newest releases for the next
10 years they had to share the spotlight
with the latest televisions cameras
and the batmobile and so that brings us
to 1995
right in the middle of the decade a 19
year old tiger woods was dominating the
amateur golf world
bill gates was busy launching the newest
version of windows with
jay leno for some reason but more
importantly
the interactive digital software
association now known as the
entertainment software association
or esa was quietly putting together the
biggest
game trade show in the world i'm kurt
lowder with mtv news connoisseurs of
video games computer effluvia and all
the latest in electronic gizmo mania
converged on los angeles last week
the annual electronic entertainment expo
better known as e3
okay 50 000 members of the press in its
first year is
hardly quiet in fact the gaming world
got an
earful of big console announcements from
the three biggest publishers at the time
sony sega and nintendo during e3 1995
sony revealed the original playstation's
release date and price
the sega saturn for some reason started
immediately shipping
to retailers and nintendo showcased the
virtual boy
ah well i i guess one out of three ain't
so bad
and that was in addition to all the
third-party developers who also showed
up 3do
capcom activision ea squaresoft all
attended but their presence was dwarfed
by none other
than acclaim who brought in over 15
different games to the show
e3's first year ended up being one of
the biggest conventions to date
and encouraged the organizers to
continue having the show
in los angeles every summer and they did
for the next two years at least while
sunny california might have been the
perfect spot for e3 due to some
unfortunate negotiation problems the
location was
actually moved to atlanta georgia for
1997 and 1998.
nevertheless e3 continued to grow in
size and upon returning to the la
convention center the attendance
remained at a steady
60 to 70 000 people strong that's quite
a lot of people
but there were quite a lot of games
there as well
e3 1999 featured sega's new dreamcast
console in full
force as well as some previews of sony's
new playstation
at e3 2000 we saw the first appearance
of computer software giant
microsoft who were preparing for the
release of their first video game
console the xbox you'll be able to get a
box just like this
with xbox in it e3 2001 was the final
appearance of sega as a console maker
after making the decision to focus on
software only
but we also got the first look at
nintendo's latest system
the gamecube as well as the first
trailer for super smash bros melee
which by the way is still one of the
biggest fighting games
today so the new big three sony nintendo
and now
microsoft kind of cruised along for a
few years it wasn't until e3
2006 that sony decided to make history
with one of the weirdest press
conferences
ever game is powered by namco it's ridge
racer
ridge racer remember that one
so here's this giant enemy crab was the
unintentional goofiness of sony's press
conference the tipping point
probably not but the giant enemy crab
sure didn't help anything
flip over this crab on its back
if he shows up and you attack its
weak point for massive damage the
following year
citing budget issues among some
publishers then esa
president doug lowenstein announced that
e3 would now be a smaller
more intimate event with an invite-only
list of about 10
000 people this shift essentially shut
out many bloggers and non-industry
professionals that had attended the show
in previous years
but with the new look also came a new
name e3
media and business summit also e3 that
year wasn't held at the typical los
angeles convention center
nor was it held in any sort of central
location at all
it was actually spread across different
venues and locations in santa monica
and if you weren't part of the industry
at the time you probably wouldn't have
even realized it was happening gone were
the gaudy displays and
sensory overload of previous years and
in their place were hotel
ballrooms and jamie kennedy from
neversoft which wasn't that the first
name for viagra i don't despite the
changes being made to try and improve
the show
it was still an exceedingly tough time
for e3 with sims creator
will wright saying that the conference
quote almost feels
like a zombie at this point but hey at
least we got a few memes
out of the deal my body my body is ready
thankfully for will wright and many
other people who once enjoyed attending
e3
the show is actually opened back up to a
larger audience in 2009 with over 40
000 people coming back to check out the
latest games such as metal gear rising
final fantasy 14
and super mario galaxy 2. the slight
misstep didn't seem to matter all that
much as e3 continued to be the biggest
name in gaming trade shows though there
has been
no shortage of awkward press conferences
in the years since
there is ubisoft's in 2015. do you have
a meme one up you want a pitch
oh we had mr caffeine in 2011. everyone
do it with me
i said and of course konami's in
2010. this is not the original hack and
slash anymore
this is an extreme
extreme heck of trash title
but as we all know e3 isn't about memes
mostly with the 27 year history behind
it there's also been changes in the way
publishers approach the show companies
like ubisoft have continuously attempted
to bring more personality and humor to
their press conferences though their
success rate is up for
debate and nintendo stopped doing live
press conferences entirely in 2013
to focus on their pre-recorded showcases
dubbed nintendo
direct and in 2017 e3 itself changed
everything by opening its doors to the
public for the very first time
meaning that anyone was able to buy
tickets and attend the show
gone are the days where the latest
gaming announcements and showcases are
coveted
for industry-centric folk the gates had
been opened to the public
it was an enormous success and a
claustrophobic one
2017 saw 68 000 attendees flocking to e3
resulting in an overcrowded convention
center with enthusiastic game players
shoulder the shoulder and butts to butts
thankfully the tradition of e3's
inclusivity to the public
continued in 2018 with the caveat
of giving industry only access for the
first few hours before
the public the result drew in 69 000
attendees making it the largest since
2005.
nice and its attendance wasn't the only
big deal
microsoft took the stage to announce the
acquisition of ninja theory undead
labs playground games and compulsion
games
bethesda kicked off with a full-blown
rock concert thanks to andrew wk
followed with todd howard staring
longingly at a map
that's right
so cool and while bethesda had the party
god
sony had flute guy in fact sony did a
lot of things different that year
instead of the usual series of teasers
and announcements
sony went all in on deep dive
presentations for the last of us part 2
goes to sushima and spider-man also
as it would turn out it would be sony's
last e3 spectacle
to this day sony opted not to
participate in 2019's e3
the first time since the expo's
inception 25 years prior
in an interview sony ceo sean laden said
that the trade show
was no longer helpful due in part to the
rapid news flow of the internet and a
shift for sony to focus on fewer
but more quality games but while sony
wasn't there
thankfully keanu reeves was
you're breathtaking which brings us to
2020 the year the world came to a halt
and pivoted in the face of the coven 19
pandemic
as a result e3 was cancelled only a
month
prior still the spirit of gaming
excitement and announcements lived on
with companies turning to their own
style of nintendo-like directs
and while we still paddle through the
ripples of the pandemic e3
is returning this year with an all
digital event
so even through its ups and downs and
even a cancellation under its belt
e3 has been and continues to be a place
for media publishers
and now the gaming public to gather and
celebrate video games and all of their
wonderful
and sometimes weird glory
so here's to more e3 to more
jaw-dropping reveals
more awkward moments and goofy press
conferences
and most importantly more games not only
new games forever
but new gamers forever
thank you very much
you